hey guys dr. Burke here in this video
we're going to talk about how to drop
one size in one week
guaranteed okay there are five things
you need to focus on we're taking all
the best strategies and putting them
together okay number one this is a
technique it's a strategy using
intrument intermittent fasting why
because every time you eat you raise
insulin insulin is the common
denominator between whether you're going
to lose weight or not lose weight
whether you're going to burn fat or not
burn fat so if there's insulin too high
forget about losing weight so if we can
eat less meals okay we're not talking
but less calories less meals less
infrequent this is going to really help
you reduce insulin and help you lose
weight so I'm gonna recommend two meals
okay you can spread them out equally
maybe a late morning and then for dinner
okay so no snacking is in between
because we don't want to raise insulin
when you eat protein 3 to 6 ounces not
too much just enough a large amount of
vegetables because we need that because
as we get into fat-burning you need to
flush all that fat out of your system
and not do necessary like a high protein
diet we're doing a a moderate amount of
protein a little bit smaller amount
we're actually doing a lot of vegetables
okay and we're gonna add some fat it's
almost impossible to do this without
adding some fat why because fat is one
of the only foods that will not raise
insulin too much and so if we can
actually do fat it's gonna allow you to
go longer even though there's more
calories we don't care about that we
care about insulin we want to keep
insulin low so this is a really good
combination of what to eat okay so we
have some protein vegetables fat all
right no snacks to meals okay number two
you're gonna need to sleep most fat
burning occurs when you are in deep
sleep you cannot do this with five to
six hours of sleep you need eight hours
minimum now even if you have to get a
nap that's totally fine if you can do
that but we need to go for eight hours
there's two things I like to do to
enhance my sleep
one is I do a lot of stretching before
bed number two I use this thing right
here it's adrenal night formula this
stuff is very powerful it doesn't have
any melatonin
basically supports the adrenal gland it
chills out the adrenal gland normally
take one before bed I would take two to
really get that eight hours of sleep you
won't feel groggy you wake up feeling
refreshed and it'll enhance the sleep
okay so that's one thing the next thing
is stress if you're going through stress
it's going to be a barrier because
stress activates the hormone called
cortisol that blocks the fat burning so
what we want to do is we want to list
all your stressors and it's probably
gonna be related to people and avoid
those people for one week and you're
gonna find surprisingly you will
actually lose more weight because if you
keep running into this situation over
and over with these stressful people
it's not helpful
I also recommend no watching the news
for one week watch a comedy we eat a
book because we don't want to interfere
that have a stress interfere with the
sleep we don't want that negativity and
then we want to do long walks okay so we
want to walking is really good and just
getting space so that's what we're gonna
do for stress there's a lot of other
things but this will be helpful and also
how sleeping more will help stress as
well now exercise you want to do high in
high intensity interval training that
means that you want to work the whole
body right now I do a combination of
bike when it's not too cold out and I do
sprints I do rock climbing I do
deadlifts which with a good posture but
you want to find something that fits
your interest but you want to do
something really high full-body upper
and lower body short duration high
intensity but only do that every two
days why because we want to get that
recovery all the benefits from exercise
happens in the recovery you don't want
to do it every day unless you're really
in shape and even every other day might
not be the best thing if you're been
suffering from sleep and stress so it
really is kind of a juggle but twice I
mean I've taken people in decrease the
frequency of their workouts and help
them lose a lot more weight and it's
quite interesting how that you it's
counterintuitive but it works on the
days you're not working out you're going
to go for a long walks and just gonna
walk and just get space so that's what
you're gonna do if you're
sighs nutrition seek help seek help why
because seek help activates the thyroid
to speed up the metabolism only consume
seek help in the morning take one or two
in the morning taking the little tablets
and don't take them before you go to bed
because it'll keep you up at night
potassium citrate now they have
potassium chlorate I'm gonna recommend
you get potassium citrate and whatever
it says in the bottle 5 exit it's going
to be like 99 milligrams so you're gonna
do 500 milligrams now that's not even
hardly a dent into the potassium
requirements that you need because you
need 4700 milligrams so why are we
recommending potassium citrate because
as you're burning fat getting into a
ketogenic diet you you're gonna be
losing a little bit of potassium we want
to put the potassium in potassium will
lower the need for insulin potassium
will enhance your asleep potassium will
prevent kidney stones potassium will
help relax the muscles and it'll
actually help your energy so again I
normally don't recommend one individual
mineral without the others in a
combination but we're just talking about
dropping some serious weight and you
don't have to do this long-term just
short-term and it's really difficult I
know it's hard to believe it's difficult
for people to consume the amount of
vegetables that they need they need
about 7 to 10 cups a day I'm trying to
get people to have even 7 cups a day so
they're not getting their potassium you
need 7 to 10 cups of vegetables every
day to get your potassium so we can
enhance it a little bit short-term but
you're going to need to do at least 5 X
that ok so calcium potassium citrate the
only contraindication would be if you
have kidney disease which is very highly
unlikely so then you wouldn't want to do
that but it's you're gonna be fine
nutritional yeast
why nutritional yeast you can get from
the health food store it's loaded with
natural be vital mints it's going to
handle kind of the stress it's gonna
help the excessive thinking it's gonna
help
chill out the adrenal glands it's gonna
tie everything in here but these are the
most
powerful things that you can do now you
might have individual specific issues
like bad mental cramps or a body issue
or whatever if you have a more complex
case and you need more help I think the
most cost-effective way to do this is to
do my membership site I have a
membership site that's very inexpensive
and you get my guidance and I actually
give you lessons a little bit each time
like you actually go through one step at
a time so it's not confusing because
people get overwhelmed so I like to kind
of spoon-feed you so you can go from
this point to this point slowly at your
own pace and you can get the knowledge
get the results having me as a backup if
you have questions so I put a link below
definitely check it out and I think we
would love to have you as part of a
member so I hope this was beneficial
thank you so much for watching and click
the link below